- Ми знаємо, хто вони такі, ми їх знайшли.
Ніого там особливого і кримінального немає.
- Вони цивільні?
- Що?
- Цивільні?
- Не чую.
- Цивільні, звісно.
Так Володимир Путін усього два тижні тому 12 вересня
заспокоював і росіян, і решту світу щодо відомих широкому загалу
під прізвищами Боширов і Петров
"російських туристів у Солсбері".
Розслідувачі з Bellingcat та Insider стверджують,
що один з тих, хто ймовірно отруїв Скрипалів,
і представився у відомому інтерв’ю як турист Руслан Боширов -
насправді - полковник російських спецслужб Анатолій Чепіга.
Про це свідчить маса документів.
Зокрема, незалежні розслідувачі
наводять витяг з системи "Російський паспорт".
У ній і фотографія, і особисті дані Чепіги.
Журналісти встановили, що Чепіга народився
у квітні 79-го року в Амурській області.
Журналісти шукали його обличчя серед випускників військових училищ,
які готують співробітників ГРУ
для операцій за кордоном та інтенсивно навчають іноземних мов.
Одним з таких є Далекосхідне вище загальновійськове командне училище,
яке з відзнакою закінчив Анатолій Чепіга.
Автори публікації переглянули фотографії випускників училища
2001-2003 років,
і на фото з Чечні знайшли людину,
яка віддалено нагадує "Боширова".
Після училища Чепіга пішов служити
у 14-у бригаду спецназу ГРУ і тричі був у відрядженнях у Чечні.
Європейські експерти вважають:
докази того, що у замаху на Скрипалів брав участь кадровий офіцер
російської зовнішньої розвідки, матимуть серйозні наслідки.
Якщо буде доведено, що російська військова розвідка
за допомогою отрути скоїла вбивство на території Великобританії,
і тим більше, якщо встановлять особи вбивць,
тоді це не просто подія зі сфери кримінальної хроніки,
у ній з'являється політична складова,
яка може ще більше погіршити відносини Росії з ЄС і США.
Але не лише це спричинило скандал.
Як з’ясувалося, у 2014 році підрозділ, в якому служив Чепіга,
помітили біля українського кордону. Тоді ж президент Росії Володимир Путін
присвоїв Анатолію Чепізі звання "Герой Росії"
"за виконання миротворчої місії".
Автори розслідування вважають,
що нагороду могли дати за участь у військових діях в Україні.
У Москві ж Чепіга закінчив Академію головного управління Генштабу Росії.
Таким чином, на цьому прикладі простежується
дуже промовистий кар’єрний шлях кадрового російського розвідника:
від Чечні - в Україну, а далі - на Солсбері.
А ще ж  поки невідові подробиці стосовно
другого підозрюваного  в отруєнні Скрипалів,
який поки відомий під іменем Олександра Петрова.
Експерти впевнені, що публікація доказів приналежності
другого "російського туриста" до спецслужб РФ,
лише питання часу. Поки ж ФСБ перевіряє,
хто з рядових російських силовиків злив в інтернет
дані анкет на отримання закордонних паспортів "Петровим і Бошировим".